hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to overnight to reboot now
this is a five nights at Freddy's 2 free
roam map inspired by Nixon who made the
joy of creation reboot and using a lot
of animations from the same person that
did the animations for the joy of
creation I've never played it but I have
a special place in my heart for five
nights at Freddy's 2 so I'm gonna try it
out there's a lot of nights that you
could do but I really only want to try
it for a little bit maybe do want to set
both versions 0.67 and I am part of the
open AI system by eel and musk I will be
your companion tonight I also have a
really deep British voice this is the
new and improved Freddy fazbear's pizza
you are a security guard here because
well I have no idea personally I have no
idea why anyone would want to work here
I have a few tips for you tonight that
puppet thing is located in price corner
you can see it by opening the cam
systems by pressing Q you can navigate
the cam systems by pressing the
different keys show ya need to
physically go the price
every so often if it arrives you're
pretty much screwed so just keep it
while w will be fine there will be one
of the something happens to you I'm not
going to tell you what happens to him
but if you make it towards the end of
the week I may tell you so how do you
get away from him it's pretty hard we
used to have a mask that you could wear
to disguise yourself but I don't know
why it stopped working and there was a
certain accident there are places for
you to hide firstly the lockers behind
you seem to be a good hiding place and
work for others before you next you have
in the vents
none of the animatronics tend to come in
here except one but you don't need to
worry about that for the moment you may
change it as a hiding space xs-1 ye the
last place to hide is a more tables
which works
oh okay thank you
oh hi it's Balloon Boy and oh my god
it's five nights at Freddy's and oh my
god apparently Bonnie is gonna be
joining me today well time to go in the
ladies restroom anything in here that I
should know about
this is so bizarre I mean cool that you
actually get to wander around this place
the last time I tried to do like a level
where you're actually in five nights at
Freddy's - oh hey mangle how you doing
was when um was when I [ __ ] hello
hello how do i whine that I have no idea
where I whine that or how I whined that
can I just leave are you staring at me I
have no idea where it actually is oh
[ __ ] oh oh [ __ ] [ __ ] oh no oh no how
do I whined you don't know where the
middle are [ __ ] [ __ ] oh hey hi oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh God huh oh boy
I don't know well [ __ ] Ellie's coming
after me oh no oh I have no idea where
to wind up the music box is this it
[ __ ] boy okay all right don't do that
I'm just gonna hide in Locker these
lockers don't [ __ ] work do they oh
boy okay yeah yeah he'll never find me
oh the music box gonna go off oh I'm
dead either way I'm dead in a million
ways I'm gonna die whoa whoa what the
[ __ ] [ __ ] whoa whoa oh my god I am
so dad hey okay hey Gibby
I'm gonna [ __ ] close it's not closing
is it oh they're not closing hi hello
stop humping my face
okay thank you thank you for that thank
you thank you okay
Jesus so I can tell that this game isn't
quite as polished as some other games
that I played and that's why I'm not
gonna do a full playthrough of it but
even so this is kind of interesting to
see the effort that's been put into this
I winded oh I got a left click 'add oh
okay alright then okay so now all I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna survive a full
night
why is my heartbeat going why would my
heartbeat be going oh okay it's probably
fine you know it's probably 100% fine
maybe if I just go on top of the stage
and just try to join everybody else and
wave Bonnie won't be able to see me and
won't know I can't even jump up on stage
this is [ __ ] alright now that I know
how to wind up the music box and now
that he's shut up I should be able to
keep away from the bond stir long enough
to survive this night as soon as he
walks out of that room I know that I'm
in trouble but I just want to see what
happens when he what the [ __ ] was that
okay all right oh I have only a limited
amount of flashlight battery oh [ __ ]
this place is much creepier oh [ __ ] is
that him
that's him okay alright so ah that's
stressful okay so he oh no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
okay
alright just calm down it's fine
everything's under control you don't
need to worry buffing everything is fine
oh [ __ ] dude that is that is extremely
terrifying holy [ __ ] [ __ ] that is
legitimately horrifying oh just the
giant beaming red light hold stop
looking at me okay yeah go down that
hallway I'm not here you stay out of my
zone don't let me into my zone whole
[ __ ] how why how and why that doesn't
make any goddamn sense
mangles going crazy over in his corner
shepard Dubinsky hey guys are you doing
okay going on okay the music box should
be fine for at least another couple
hours I'm just gonna go down here to try
to stay away from him oh I can I don't
earth at desk okay so so long as he
doesn't kill me I'll be fine amazing how
that works that was intelligent
commentary on my part self fine yeah
he's come to kill me it is really
interesting to see you like this again
it's not the best made but at least is
better than that gmod map hello I see
what the [ __ ] whoa
I do not appreciate that oh god why are
you coming down here why are you coming
down here why are you coming down here
it's like you know you know I don't like
that oh I don't like that okay
whoa the [ __ ] [ __ ] okay no dude oh
dude oh no dude love the way you walk is
so stupid dude oh dude okay I may have
[ __ ] myself over because I have no
idea how I'm gonna get around him to get
back oh no dude I might be able to sneak
by if he goes past the tables a little
bit
what hey what the [ __ ] geez calm down
enough that I can get past you
[ __ ] that's not gonna work but maybe I
can go around hmm
I gotta get over there I gotta get over
there oh okay I'm okay I'm okay I'm okay
okay all right wind up the music box
okay and then hide under the tables
that's what he said he said in my work
not always why is mangle being a [ __ ]
over there okay so far so good this is
actually legitimately more stressful
than I thought and only one animatronic
is active this is cool like I like the
effort and another fact that I was gonna
save until later this is this was made
by a kid who's 13 like it's pretty well
done for a kid who's 13 which is awfully
like it's just like people are getting
started so early these days and they're
actually trying stuff in their making
and obviously it's somewhat derivative
it's it's five nights at Freddy's 2 like
it's using something else's inspiration
but the fact that it's done and it's
done pretty well that is pretty
terrifying and I mean the animations
weren't made by a thirteen-year-old
they're they're made by I forget the gut
in the name of the guy if it's in the
credits I'll remember the name but this
guy does really really good work and
especially in making these horrifying
monstrosity come to life it seems like I
might be okay might get through this
night maybe I maybe I'm gonna try
another night because I want to see what
happens when there's more animatronics
roaming around and how horrible that
would be so as soon as we get through
this one we'll be okay it's weird
whenever you're under a table your
heartbeat goes up whenever you're in the
vents whenever it thinks that you're
actually hiding your heartbeat goes up
this is kind of a nice feature so you
know when you're actually quote-unquote
hidden what is your sign say your sign
doesn't say anything dick do you not
know how to spell [ __ ] you gave me so
much trouble in five nights at Freddy's
2 and for what good reason none gotten
you to stop pivot hi hello alright I did
it I'm gonna try one more
I was only gonna do one egg but I'm
actually curious enough to see the
second one like I want to know I want to
know like what it involves when all
these guys are doing their thing so I
got a no I gots to know I gots to know
and you want to before we get started I
have some prizes for you at the end of
the week because of your potential hard
work yay one sexy mozzarellas to a bag
of cash three exotic butters Oh anyway
back to your shipping tonight okay
Bonnie will be active again tonight and
you know how to treat him but Freddy may
also be active you can make sure it
stays inactive by turning off the radio
that is always playing music Freddy is
attracted to this music so make sure you
turn it off as soon as you hear it the
radio is near the parts and services
rule since I do not know your
I shall randomly generate a name for you
hello eggs benedict so fun
okay please see you tomorrow buddy
thanks pal I like all the references to
sister location and I'll take the bag of
cash as much as I like exotic butters
insert exotic butter shop I think I
think I'll - oh that's not good Freddy
Freddy pretty what are you doing Freddy
Freddy Freddy what you doing ready ready
I did not ask for you to be here Freddie
I didn't even hear your radio Freddy
whoa okay that's creepy
hello huh okay can i oh [ __ ] oh oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] he's got purple eyes oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] no no thank you nothing turn up
what the fire how did I turn it off how
do I turn that off I have no idea I
tried to go oh my god
[ __ ] stop stop I'm trying to turn it
off but it's not working
yeah it's not working sorry oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude I don't know how to turn you
off oh boy well death approaches bring
it on [ __ ] [ __ ] you
oh [ __ ] that was pretty gravy alright
wait what does that say does that say
there's something there's words there
them save save them save them I have no
idea what that means and I have no idea
why that is anyway so that is overnight
to reborn or remixed or whatever it is
it's overnight - it's not bad this is
legitimately good I'm not gonna do a
full playthrough of it because you know
I I just don't want to do too many of
these five nights at freddys fan games
but I just want to say this is
legitimately cool I mean of course it
could use some polish of course it could
be refined down of course the
environment could be more detailed and
whatnot and of course the controls could
be tighter there's a lot of improvements
to be made but it's still legitimately
good like I like this it brings back
memories of me playing five nights at
Freddy's 2 it was legitimately scary at
times to see those things stomping
through the hallways like having that
free roam aspect and knowing the world
of five nights at Freddy's does bring
this kind of horrifying atmosphere to
the game so it's pretty good it could
use some polish but still not bad - the
developer Christian Blandford keep it up
you've got a lot of potential in you
you've got a lot of potential here you
could do a lot with this so keep moving
forward with it and everybody watching
let me know what you thought down in the
comments below and maybe give some
encouragement to the developer here and
thanks to the animator who I still don't
know the name of but when I find it out
I'll write it over here because they've
done great work on this one and the joy
of creation so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video
[Music]